Alyssa Milano leads a campaign against
sex in order to fight Georgia's pro-life
law Harvard punishes in academic for
defending Harvey Weinstein and Democrats
move closer to impeachment i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show i
[Music]
hope you all had a wonderful weekend I
know I did so we will talk about all of
the things in the news in just a second
first hye-rin used to be hard multiple
job sites stacks of resumes a confusing
review process but today hiren can be
easy you only have to go to one place to
get it done zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire zip recruiter sends your jobs
to over a hundred of the web's leading
job boards but they don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and then invites them to apply to your
job as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one spotlights
the top candidates so you never miss a
great match zip recruiter is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that's
zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly WI re
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire you
want to up your game you want your hires
to be better you want to make sure you
have the best employees there's only one
way to do it zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire there is a reason we use zip
recruiter every time we look to make a
new hire over at daily wired check them
out right now zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire okay so the left has decided
that the end of the world is nigh in
Georgia according to some of the world's
best journalists apparently George's new
heartbeat bill which protects the lives
of the unborn
you know unborn children human lives
that bill barbaric dark ages terrible
not only barbaric ins our cage isn't
terrible according to some of these
brilliant folks but apparently leads to
the possibility that women will be
prosecuted if they have a miscarriage in
Georgia it will be the end of the world
captain dog sleeping together all the
rest of this crap okay here's the
reality
the bill does no such thing David French
has a great piece of our National Review
explaining the legality behind the
Georgia law he points out that the law
not only bans abortion when the baby has
a detectable human heartbeat it declares
the scientific philosophical and
theological truth that an unborn child
is a natural person under state law in
fact the law
even goes so far as to ensure that a guy
who knocks up a woman has to provide
child support for her pregnancy French
points out he says I expected activist
resistance and protest against the bill
I expected radical voices to urge
corporate boycotts of Georgia I must
confess I did not expect to see a series
of stories with lurid headlines and fun
saline fundamentally mistaken premises
go viral and stay viral for days here is
a sampling Georgia it's late Georgia
just criminalized abortion women who
terminate their pregnancies would
receive life in prison the week
Georgia's heartbeat abortion bill could
imprison women for life all of this is
garbage
all of it is untrue all of it is slanted
news and fake news and stupidity and
biased okay because here is the truth
this is not what the law says the
stories are viral because they rely says
French on facially plausible reasoning
since Georgia declared all unborn
children to be natural persons then
Georgia's conventional murder statute
must apply to women who self-terminate
but this is fundamentally wrong the
heartbeat bill did not repeal a number
of Georgia criminal statutes that
explicitly applied to abortions and
unborn children and it does not overrule
controlling legal authority holding that
these statutes by our prosecution of a
woman for terminating her own pregnancy
it is not the pro-life position nor has
it been as far as I'm aware ever that
women who self terminate pregnancies
ought to be prosecuted this is simply
not a pro-life position a Donald Trump
you'll recall in 2016
made implications that he might want to
prosecute women who did this and the
entire pro-life movement came down on
his head so when folks on the Left
people on the social left journalists
who lie say things like this bill is
going to criminalize women whose self or
who have miscarriages like accidental
miscarriages it is just not true
first as French points out there is a
specific Code section that applies to
unlawful abortions Georgia Code section
16 12 140 states quote a person commits
the offense of criminal abortion when in
violation of code section 16 12 141 he
or she administers any medicine drugs or
other substance whatever to any woman or
when he or she uses any instruments or
other means whatever upon any woman with
intent to produce a miscarriage or
abortion a person convicted of the
offense of criminal abortion shall be
punished by imprisonment for not less
than one nor more than 10 years code
section 16 12 141 is the exact session
that was amended to include the
heartbeat
provision if a person performs an
abortion in violation of the heartbeat
bill then Code section 1612 140 applies
it does not impose life imprisonment on
anybody Georgia courts have held it does
not apply to a woman whose self
terminates only to third parties who
perform an abortion which again is the
traditional pro-life position but people
who don't know anything say differently
because they're liars in Hillman versus
state the court of appeals of Georgia
rejected the prosecution's efforts to
imprison a woman who shot herself in the
stomach to kill her unborn child
interpreting 1612 1:40 it said quote
this statute is written in the third
person clearly indicating that at least
two actors must be involved accordingly
it does not criminalize a pregnant
woman's actions in securing an abortion
regardless of the means utilized
sectioned second the Georgia Code
section that criminalizes feticide such
as when a man attacks a woman for
purpose of killing her unborn baby
specifically says quote nothing in this
Code section shall be construed to
permit the prosecution of any woman with
respect to her unborn child taken
together these statutes mean that a
woman cannot be prosecuted either for
aborting her own baby or committing
feticide if you're still skeptical about
my argument perhaps you'll believe a
Planned Parenthood representative
responding to a query from the
washington post the post fat check
claims that the georgia bill
criminalized women who terminated their
own pregnancies and found those claims
incorrect is a quote from the washington
post quote the news headlines and social
media headlines that speculate about the
bill's unintended consequences are at
the very least not productive and most
they're harmful this is according to
Planned Parenthood's Stacey Fox HP what
481 could not be used to successfully
prosecute women she argued she says if a
woman had a miscarriage she could be
pulled into an investigation looking at
whether someone had performed an illegal
abortion on her but again that is not
for purposes of prosecuting the woman
nor is the suggestion that a woman could
be jailed for a miscarriage that's a
bunch of crap put out by badly motivated
people who are liars that's a far far
cry from the heavens above says David
French but the truth isn't stopping the
falsehood from rocketing around social
media so with that in mind it is
important to see how the left has
responded to the lie how they how they
push the lie how they exacerbate the lie
and then how they on the back of this
use the woke lie in order to promote
some of the dumbest boycott policy I
have happen in my life so first you're
seeing corporation saying that they're
going to boycott
they won't film in Georgia well I'm sure
that that's gonna change the lives of
pro lifers I'm sure that all the pro
lifers in the state of Georgia will
suddenly be okay with the killing of the
unborn so long as you guys don't bring
your production of Hangover Part 4 to
Georgia that's gonna change everything
guys
but according to NBC News Hollywood it
just shows you where Hollywood is that
they really care deeply about abortion
abortion is the Hollywood litmus test
there are two litmus tests for morality
in Hollywood 1 are you okay with killing
unborn children and 2 how do you feel
about same-sex marriage now it used to
be the same-sex marriage is really the
only test you could be pro-life in
Hollywood sort of but the fact is you're
not really allowed to be pro-life
anymore if you're pro-life in Hollywood
this is a symptom of you being a crazed
religious fanatic or as Chris Cuomo the
very objective journalist on CNN has
said the only reason to be pro-life is
faith and feelings which is utter crap
and garbage obviously when it comes to
Hollywood I mean I remember I did a book
called primetime propaganda this is back
in 2013-2014 2012 maybe in any case my
book was about Hollywood and how
Hollywood is biased against
conservatives one of the people I
interviewed for the book was Patricia
Heaton Patti Heaton has been the star of
multiple sitcoms she was the star of
Everybody Loves Raymond she played
Ramon's wife she was the star of the
middle she's been a consistent fixture
on television for years and I remember I
interviewed her and because Patty is
deeply pro-life she's Catholic and she
is deeply pro-life and I asked her do
you feel that you've ever lost a job
because of your pro-life position and
should know I've been working
consistently in town for twenty years
and she said can I call you back
two days later I received a call from
patty and she said I've been calling
around I called my agent I called a
bunch of people they never told me this
but I've lost seven specific jobs due to
being pro-life one of the litmus tests
in Hollywood is whether you're in favor
of the quote-unquote right of a woman to
kill an unborn child and have an
abortion doctor do it right this is one
of the moral questions of the day
because morality in Hollywood is
completely upside-down if you wish to
raise your child religious evil if you
wish to kill your child in the womb good
that's the basic logical morality of
Hollywood unfortunately so now Hollywood
is declaring that it's going to boycott
Georgia it's funny I don't remember
Hollywood boycotting Hollywood after
Harvey Weinstein
I don't remember Hollywood boycotting
Hollywood after Oscars so white I
remember any of this stuff but I do
remember Hollywood trying to boycott the
state of Georgia okay so according to
NBC News multiple production companies
have announced they will no longer film
in Georgia after the state passed a
restrictive abortion law the law signed
by Governor Brian Kemp a Republican on
Tuesday bans abortion once a fetal
heartbeat can be detected which can be
as early as six weeks before some women
even know they are pregnant Georgia has
quietly become a major production
location for film and television largely
because of tax incentives the state
offers in 2016 according to the
nonprofit film la 17 of the year's top
100 films were produced in Georgia more
than in California because it turns out
that Democrats in California don't like
the economic policies that they vote for
so they went for these crap economic
policies in my home state and then they
can't stand the heat and so they get out
of the kitchen and they go to Georgia
Kemp said this year the industry employs
around 200,000 Georgians and brings in
tens of billions of dollars of revenue
to the state David Simon who's the
creator of The Wire and a far leftist
said his production company will cease
filming in the state he tweeted quote
our comparative assessments of locations
for upcoming development will pull
georgia off the list until we can be
assured the health options and civil
liberties of our female colleagues are
unimpaired if you truly believe that
Georgia is gonna change its abortion
policy because frickin David Simon ain't
gonna film there I don't think you
understand pro-life people for pro-life
people this bill is the equivalent of
the abolition of slavery and if you
think that those people are gonna be
like yeah you know what let's go back to
the killing of babies because they
desperately need David Simon's latest TV
show here think again mark Duplass a
delightful fellow my personally no
tweeted quote don't give your business
to Georgia and asked other producers to
join him he says will you pledge with me
not to film anything in Georgia until
they reverse this backwards legislation
I pledge that I won't watch any of your
overrated films mark Duplass mark
Duplass by the way is a is a truly
powered Lee individual I mean it truly
cowardly individual tell you marked
applause story in just one second
because we have a really good mark
Duplass story here at the Daily wire but
first for decades credit cards have been
telling us to buy it now and pay for it
later with interest despite your best
intentions that interest can get out of
control fast with Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one
monthly payment since 2007 Lending Club
has helped millions of people regain
control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trips to a bank no high interest credit
cards just go to Lending Club com tell
them about yourself how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right for
you if you are approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
35 billion dollars in loans issued go to
Lending Club com /ban check your rate in
minutes borrow up to 40 grand that is
Lending Club comm slash been Lending
Club comm slash been all loans made by
web bank member FDIC Equal Housing
lender go check it out right now there
is no reason for you to suffer through
these incredibly high interest rates
instead consolidate your debt do the
responsible financial thing and make
sure that your financial house is in
order an easy way to do that head over
to Lending Club comm slash Ben right now
you can check that rate minutes power up
to 40 grand that's Lending Club comm
slash been so quick sidenote before I
get to my mark Duplass story so the
quick side note is this all these folks
in Hollywood who think that they are
punishing the state of Georgia by not
relocating in Georgia for their filming
you think the people who work on their
films in Georgia are by and large the
people who voted for Brian Kemp they're
punishing the very people who are allied
with their political allies they're
punishing their own political allies in
Georgia but again political cowardice is
is the nature of the folks in California
they won't stay in California and pay
their fair share
instead they hijack it too they hightail
it to Georgia to take advantage of the
tax benefits and then when Georgia
doesn't act like California with regard
to pro-life laws then all of a sudden
we're not going to go there we're not
gonna go that why because they're
cowards and not only are they cowards
they're vicious cowards I haven't seen a
lot of conservatives say we're not doing
business in New York or California
thanks to their immoral abortion laws
they continued up to recognize that we
live in a republic and that it is good
to do business with people with whom you
disagree because we still have to share
this republic folks on the Left are
basically creating a two-track America
whether they are boycotting North
Carolina for trying to preserve gendered
bathrooms in state law or whether they
are boycotting Georgia and its attempt
to boycott in its attempts to save the
lives of the unborn
it's pretty amazing okay so here's the
mark Duplass story which I think tells
you what you need to know about the
moral backbone of Hollywood so mark
Duplass happens to be
fairly talented guy he's been on some TV
shows he's produced some films and Mark
Duplass came to our office here at Daily
wire because he wanted to spend some
time with me he reached out to me
because he was doing a film on the
Second Amendment and he wanted to make
sure that it wasn't biased too far in
one direction or the other so he wanted
to know the pro-gun arguments which is
great so he came in I even met an hour
and a half of my time and as he left I
warned him dude do not tweet that you
have been here because if you tweet that
you have been here your own side will
stab you in the back like the Nights
Watch - John like that's why that's how
this will go and he did not believe me
about three weeks later for no real
reason he tweets out that I am a
well-intentioned fellow which is a
statement which I happen to agree I have
count conversations with folks all the
time on the left so well so long as
they're not badly motivated I have lots
of conversations with people on the left
on a regular basis and Duplass tweets
out that I'm a nice guy who is one
motivated and Duplass then gets hit with
a wave a raft of leftists saying no he's
the worst person who ever lived he's so
terrible Duplass not only pulls down the
tweet saying that I'm a decent person he
then puts up a new tweet saying that he
opposes all forms of racism sexism
bigotry and homophobia so when it comes
to woke scolding do pluses is definitely
at the top of the list and the cowardice
of people who won't have conversations
the cowardice of people who simply
decide that because they opposed
George's abortion while they're not
boycotting the state is pretty
astonishing now this goes to some pretty
insane lengths and the most insane
lengths of course come courtesy of
Alyssa Milano so Alyssa Milano is a
pretty untalented actress who used to be
I'm charmed and she decided that she was
going to initiate a recap of Lysistrata
that she was Shue saying that women
feminists should not have sex with their
boyfriends until Georgia repeals its law
so she tweeted out quote this is with
hashtag sex strike if your choice is
ours it not if our choices are denied so
are yours quote our reproductive rights
are being erased until women have legal
control over our own bodies we just
cannot risk pregnancy join me by not
having sex until we get bodily autonomy
back I'm calling for a sex strike pass
it on so a few things about this because
it's pretty freaking great
a few things about this first of all I
soon will listen Milano's boyfriend or
husband she married I think she's
married I assume that her husband agrees
with her on politics so she's now
telling her woke husband she will not
sleep with him because she's mad at
Brian Kemp in Georgia first of all if
you're in the boudoir and your girl is
bringing up Brian Kemp in Georgia you
got a problem you got a problem second
of all I I love that the left is now
through a backdoor method rediscovering
traditional morality so Alyssa Milano
tweets we can love and set we can love
sex and fight for our bodily autonomy
there are lots of alternatives to sis
men protect your vagina's ladies men in
positions of power are trying to
legislate them hashtag sex strike so I'm
confused first of all babies growing
uterus is not in vaginas a second of all
I don't know how you legislate a vagina
very weird I don't know what would that
legislation look like section 10 B 8
vagina that's just like a vagina and
then my favorite here is that she says
we can you can get so you can continue
have sex just not with a sis man so you
can have sex with a transgender man I
guess so a woman a bodily woman who says
she is a man you can have sex with or
with another woman but I was informed by
the woke left that sexual orientation is
completely non malleable I was informed
by the left that if you are a straight
woman just as if you are a gay woman you
can't just switch and start having sex
with people whom your biology does not
attract you to I mean so which is it
Alyssa Milano there's so many woke
problems with this tweet also it says
protect your vagina's ladies ladies what
kind of sister normative heteronormative
nonsense is this
not all Hey lots of men have vaginas
Alyssa Milano by the way it's hilarious
somebody actually tweeted that at her so
some woke person tweeted at her not all
ladies have vaginas some have penises
it's not hard to put sis before ladies
but you chose not to try and that's
transphobic behavior and then Alyssa
Milano tweeted back you're right if I
could edit I would thank you
the woke miss so a man who says he's a
woman is a real woman so you can have
sex I guess also with the traditional
system an so long as he says that he is
not sis right so long as he is just a
normal biological man who says he's what
so I guess Alyssa Milano has a way out
just gets her husband to identify as a
woman and then they're having lesbian
sex and everything's cool so I guess
that provides an easy way out but my
favorite part go back to the first tweet
for a second the first sweep where she
says our reproductive rights are being
erased until women have legal control
over our own bodies we cannot risk
pregnancy join me by not having sex
until we get bodily autonomy back
congratulations and welcome to
traditional marriage Alyssa Milano
congratulations to you so as a virgin
until marriage a person who believes
that it is moral to be abstinent until
you are having sex with a person with
whom that you would not mind having a
baby welcome to my world Alyssa Milano
where it turns out that if you don't
want to you know produce a baby that
you're gonna kill in the womb then maybe
you shouldn't have sex with that person
it's hilarious and she's seeing this
that this is such a it's such a negative
until women can abort their babies again
they should only have sex with men with
whom they are willing to have babies
okay like yeah that was called marriage
that's called traditional sexual
morality where you don't screw people
you're not willing to have a baby with
sounds good to me so I'm all for this
I'm on board with the sex strike because
you know what frankly I don't care
whether feminists like Alyssa Milano
have sex makes no difference to me your
choice lady has no impact on me
second if women are encouraged not to
have sex until they are in a place where
they aren't going to be comfortable
having a baby net societal win in a
massive way so I'm fully on board with
hashtag sex strike I think this is great
I think this is great and I totally
endorse it I'm happy to jump on board so
sign me up for Alyssa Milano's mission
to get feminists to stop having sex with
men unless they are willing to get
married to them and have a baby
you know who else on board with that
every traditional morally every
traditional moral person so that is
pretty spectacular stuff the left
self-ownership is quite pleasant on this
particular issue I've truly enjoyed it
but it didn't stop there it didn't stop
there
so yesterday of course was Mother's Day
and there's always a great irony on
mother
I have a traditional joke that I always
say on Mother's Day because the left is
so perverse on issues related to gender
I have a traditional joke it's so funny
people online are noticing that I tell
this joke every mother's and Father's
Day yes yes I do because I keep
reinforcing the same point you think I
don't know that guys of course I know it
what I always suite on Mother's Day is
happy legal guardian of unspecified
gender day because according to the left
I am confused a mother can be a man a
mother can be a woman a mother can be
anything and as far as what actually
constitutes a mother I assume that you
just mean a legal guardian so yes it is
a joke it is a joke upon those who are
woke hey so on Mother's Day the left
which was promote simultaneously
promoting abortion is tweeting out these
very sweet photos of their own children
I'm so Alyssa Milano who's promoting I'm
not gonna have sex until abortion is
allowed and also says that women should
have sex
apparently not with men not with sis men
but with other women or transgender men
or transgender women
I guess she's tweeting out this very
traditional photo happy Mother's Day
what an amazing gift it is to have these
two wonders and prepare them for life
and love a very wise friend told me
yesterday we have a singular purpose on
our short time on this planet to love
and be loved I concur
I wish you all a beautiful day unless
you're an unborn baby in that case I
hope they suck your brains into a sink
because hell that's a choice
ladies come on all right in a second
we'll get to more Mother's Day messages
from the woke but first admit it you
think cyber crime is something that
happens to other people you might think
no one wants your data or that hackers
can't grab your passwords or credit card
details you would be wrong stealing data
from unsuspecting people on public Wi-Fi
it's one of the simplest and cheapest
ways for hackers to make money when you
leave your internet connection
unencrypted you may as well be writing
your passwords and credit card numbers
on a huge billboard for the rest of the
world to see that's why I decided to
take action to protect myself from cyber
criminals I use Express VPN expressvpn
secures and anonymizes your internet
browsing by encrypting your data and
hiding your public IP address expressvpn
has easy-to-use apps that run seamlessly
in the background of your computer phone
and tablet turning on expressvpn
protection that only takes one click
using expressvpn I can safely surf on
public Wi-Fi without being snooped on or
having my personal data stolen for less
than seven bucks a month you can get the
same expressvpn protection that I have
expressvpn
rated the number one VPN service by
TechRadar it comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee protect your online
activity today find out how you can get
three months for free and expressvpn
comm / pen that's expr ESS VPN comm /
pen for three months free with a
one-year package visit expressvpn comm /
pen to learn more go check them out
right now expressvpn comm so I spend no
reason to expose your personal info to
hackers make sure that you're protected
expressvpn comm / Ben to learn more and
so it wasn't just Alyssa Milano tweeting
out happy Mother's Day
she also retweeted Kirsten Gillibrand
tweet on mothers so Kristen Gillibrand
tweeted out quote to the mothers who
have yet to be reunited with their
children after being separated at the
border mothers whose children were taken
by gun violence or illness mothers who
have lost a child or children who have
lost their mothers I'm holding you in my
heart today and always which is nice
except for the Kristin Gillibrand is
totally fine with late term abortion so
apparently I do love people who
celebrate motherhood and also celebrate
abortion celebrate it and it's not
Leanna when the head of Planned
Parenthood did this routine so she runs
an organization that kills 300,000
unborn children a year and she tweeted
out a picture of herself with her kid
and her husband says as the mother of my
beautiful 20 month old son I am proud to
march for moms so that all our children
grow up in a society that ensures health
care is a fundamental right for all not
a privilege reserved only for some
hashtag beyond Mother's Day well if you
want to ensure that health health care
is a fundamental right for all how about
you include the baby in that you're
holding one they're holding their own
child but according to you if we reverse
the clock 21 months because it's a 20
month old son your verse the clock 21
months totally kill that thing totally
fine and you know what just a choice
just the way things ought to be if you
can see the perverse morality of that I
don't know what to tell you because
obviously that is a perversion but the
left has moved from safe legal and rare
to abortion should be celebrated now we
have Amanda Palmer who is apparently a
singer-songwriter and performance artist
the LA Times is a long article about
Amanda Palmer over the weekend says
Amanda Palmer never plans to release
another album she certainly didn't need
to since 2012 the singer-songwriter and
performance artist has relied entirely
on her fans to fund the piecemeal
creation of her new work
apparently she grosses more than a
hundred thousand dollars a month
from her nearly 15,000 patreon
subscribers incoming equality alert guys
but apparently she needs to create a new
album why because she is worried about
abortion quote Palmer also publishes an
accompanying book which is part memoir
and part liner notes it includes lyrics
stream-of-consciousness essays and lush
photos of the 43 year old artist
sometimes nude and styled like a
Renaissance era goddess it has already
sold out on Palmers website a
substantial part of her news show
involves Palmer's three abortions - in
her 30s and one at age 17 hey don't tell
me that you don't know how to use birth
control you're in your 30s and yet two
abortions if you are using abortion as a
form of birth control you are doing
something deeply morally wrong there's a
deep evil to knowing better and
producing a human life and then snuffing
it out because you were too
irresponsible to use birth control she
says there is no part of me that woke up
one morning and said I know what would
be great I'll go out and sit on stage
and talk graphically about my abortions
but the state of the union seems to
insist upon it palmer is referring to
these scary
six-week abortion bans signed into law
this year in states including Ohio
Mississippi and Georgia she's offering
abortion providers free tickets to her
shows nationwide as an attempt to show
support and normalize access to
reproductive health care the euphemisms
here are astonishing normalizing access
to reproductive health care that means
that she's gonna champion abortion she
says the truth is really liberating it's
one thing to read it on the internet
it's another thing to sit in a room with
someone and say listen this is how I
felt when this happened you're not alone
and you're not crazy Palmer says the
political climate gave her the push she
needed to make there will be no
intermission for which she began to
entertain the idea about two years ago
it was a nerve-wracking proposition for
the one-time front woman for the cabaret
punk group Dresden Dolls she'd vowed to
stay away from the shackles of the
idiotic album cycle but now she felt the
necessity to do something she said she
figured that no one would pay attention
to her and her political messaging about
reproductive rights unless she played by
the music industry's rules and released
a full-length album
I knew I'd only be able to get on the
phone with someone from the LA Times if
I put a record out I know that's how it
works the tracks on the resulting album
are so dire
so dark that a mother's confession a ten
minute plus song about ash falling from
a shelf Palmer placed him on as a baby
almost sounds comedic
by comparison because she has a baby and
put the baby on a shelf and maybe fell
and she says at least the baby didn't
die she sings in the chorus we were both
into the idea this would be an
unapologetic record of vulnerability it
was obvious to me this was not going to
be a commercial record all that mattered
was that John and I were gonna try and
make this record as beautiful and as
honest as possible she said this is the
weirdest thing I've ever done it's like
a stand up show about abortion nothing
quite says morality like a stand up show
about abortion these are our moral
betters these are the people who should
dictate which human life gets protected
these are the people we should respect
and they give false stories about what
exactly the abortion law does and also
the people we should respect when they
pull their funding from the state of
Georgia I really think that people like
Amanda Palmer those are the people who I
should trust when it comes to the
protection of the unborn when it comes
to the protection of human life well the
woke schools had their self quite a
weekend a pretty incredible Twitter has
now apparently blocked and then I guess
unblocked after after some pressure they
blocked an expert PhD psychologist who
helped write the official psychological
position on transgender identity on
Saturday Rae Blanchard the PhD
psychologist an adjunct professor at the
University of Toronto who served on the
working group for gender dysphoria which
is the psychological conditioning mental
disorder as named by the dsm-5 hey in
the in the lexicon of mental disorders
gender dysphoria appears it is in fact a
mental disorder when I say that folks
suffer from gender dysphoria are
suffering from a mental illness this is
what I mean it is a disorder it is
labeled so by the dsm-5 this is an
uncontroversial scientific position but
it is so controversial now and the left
is so woke on this that they banned the
guy who wrote the rules for the dsm-5
rave Lynch heard he tweeted out his
clinically informed opinion on
transgender identity he still believes
that sex change surgery is the best
treatment first kick for a carefully
screened adult patients whose gender
dysphoria has proven resistant to other
forms of treatment but he opposed
treating children who may change their
minds and this got him blocked on
Twitter he said sex change surgery
should not be considered for any
patients until that patient has reached
the age of 21 years and has lived for at
least two years in the desired gender
role this is controversial because there
are so many people on
whoa left whoo without any data to
support them want to give puberty
blockers to children
he said sexy and and he defended his
risk for this restriction
he said gender dysphoria is not a sexual
orientation it is virtually always
preceded or accompanied by an atypical
sexual orientation in males either
homosexuality or auto china philia there
are two main types of gender dysphoria
in males one associated with
homosexuality one associated with Otto
Kahn ophelia traditionally the great
bulk of female-to-male transsexuals have
been homosexual in erotic object choice
this is all true and this is why he
ended up getting banned from Twitter
temporarily they blocked him on Twitter
Jessie single a contributing writer who
happens to be honest at New York
magazine I disagreed Jessie a lot but at
least he's an honest guy he expressed
his fear that as a journalist who often
writes about science he worries he will
not be able to continue using Twitter he
says gender dysphoria is in the dsm-5
despite endless rumor mongering and
misinformation to the contrary it is
considered a mental disorder perhaps it
shouldn't be but it's beyond insane to
suspend someone for expressing an
opinion which lines up with the DSM it
is also true that the reason that it was
relabeled gender dysphoria had nothing
to do with science and everything to do
with politics he says we are approaching
a Soviet fundamentalist take your pick
level of science denialism well I'm so
glad but I'm so glad that the woke left
is here to inform actual psychologists
that they cannot use you know
biologically correct terms pretty
incredible we'll get to more woke idiocy
in just a second first you're gonna have
to go over to daily wire.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can
subscribe over at daily we're calm when
you do you get the rest of this show
live you get the rest of the Andrew
Klavan show live there so Michael mol
shall live the rest of the Matt Walsh
alive Matt had himself a weekend as well
let a pro-life rally in Philadelphia
which was apparently huge we'll talk to
him later today on our radio show we
have two additional hours of this show
every single day we are providing tons
of content which is why you should join
us it's a lot of fun we have lots of
guests we have good times good humor
good drinks
that's good times so go check that out
right now for $9.99 a month you also get
for $99 a year this the very greatest
and beverage vessels leftist here's hot
or cold tumblr go check this out right
now constantly overflowing with the
frustration of leftists so you can go
check
right this very instant it's join the
group help us prevent ourselves from
being Z platform because left obviously
would like to do that unfortunately but
go check us out right now also check us
out of youtuber iTunes we are the second
largest podcast in America by numbers
make us number one by helping us at
YouTube in iTunes go check us out right
now we're the largest conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay other woke skulls array over the
weekend apparently Harvard just that it
just let go its first black faculty
Dean's why because these black faculty
Dean's are doing the defense lawyer in
for Harvey Weinstein so according to the
New York Times Harvard said on Saturday
a wall professor representing Harvey
Weinstein would not continue as faculty
Dean of an undergraduate house after his
term ends on June 30th the professor
Ronald Sullivan jr. and his wife
Stephanie Robinson who's a lecturer at
the Law School have been the faculty
Dean's Winthrop house one of Harvard's
residential houses for undergrad
students since 2009 they were the first
black faculty Dean's in Harvard's
history but when Sullivan joined the
defense team of mr. Weinstein the
Hollywood producer in January many
students expressed dismay saying that
his decision to represent a person
accused of abusing women disqualified
mr. Sullivan from serving in a role of
support and mentorship to students
Weinstein is scheduled to go on trial in
September in Manhattan on rape and
related charges as the protests
continued with graffiti aimed at mr.
Sullivan appearing on a university
building Harvard administrators said
they would conduct what they called the
climate review of Winthrop house in
recent weeks tensions have escalated
with a student sit-in in a lawsuit
sparked by a clash between one of the
protest leaders and two Winthrop house
staff members who are seen as supporting
mr. Sullivan so these so called
snowflakes at Harvard were complaining
because a lawyer was defending a client
so this is the way that works now as
y'all know I went to Harvard Law School
one of the more prominent professors
there was Alan Dershowitz
Alan Dershowitz defended OJ Simpson not
only were there no press at Harvard Law
four years ever I was at an event where
Ellen Dershowitz personally auctioned
off a signed exercise bicycle from OJ
Simpson and no one cared no one cared
he's a lawyer you know what lawyers do
they often defend clients and they often
defend clients who are accused and are
guilty john adams was famously one of
the first harvard law students and john
adams or at least an early harvard law
student and john adams defended the
british in the boston massacre
I guess now this would get him kicked
out of Harvard Law when I talk about
people who are snowflakes what I mean is
people who cannot handle an opposing
philosophical or political position and
these folks who are snowflakes at
Harvard who cannot handle some
I don't even agree Harvey Weinstein's a
piece of crap he's an evil human being
but a lawyer defending him that's not a
reason to deep platform him somebody at
Harvard and go graffiti Winthrop house
the fact that Harvard caves - this is
despicable
on Saturday the Dean of Harvard College
Rakesh Khurana sent an email to students
and staff members at Winthrop house
informing them he would not renew the
appointments of mr. Sullivan and Miss
Robinson as faculty Dean's after their
terms end on June 30th mr. Khurana said
in an e-mail that his decision was
informed by a number of considerations
over the past few weeks students and
staff have continued to communicate
concerns about the climate and Winthrop
house to the college he wrote the
concerns expressed have been serious and
numerous the actions that have been
taken to improve the climate have been
ineffective a noticeable lack of faculty
team presence during critical moments
has further deteriorated the climate in
the house I have concluded that the
situation in the house is untenable ok
this is the hecklers veto this is a
bunch of people who were whining that
Sullivan was being a lawyer and his wife
was being a lawyer and now they are
being z platformed from there they're
being fired from a position effectively
because they are acting as lawyers for
somebody that people don't like pretty
incredible Sullivan and Robinson said
quote we are surprised and dismayed by
the action Harvard announced today we
believe the discussions we are having
with a high-level university
representative are progressing in a
positive manner but Harvard unilaterally
ended those talks he says we will now
take some time to process Harvard's
actions and consider our options we are
sorry that Harvard's actions and the
controversy surrounding us has
contributed to the stress on Winthrop
students at this already stressful time
the contours he highlighted a conflict
between the legal principle that every
accused person demands a vigorous
defense and students demands that
college officials show support for
victims of sexual assault whose side are
you on demands in one of the
spray-painted messages directed at mr.
Sullivan earlier this year this is mob
rule is truly is mob rule we have a
legal process for determining guilt and
innocence in the country a lawyer
providing defense to a client is not an
excuse for suggesting that I mean this
is basically a lynch mob mentality that
you're going to go after the lawyer of a
person that you want to see punished and
I want to see punished and we all want
to see punished does not mean that the
lawyer himself is doing something evil
or wrong I mean this is too
to cave to these sort of woke scolds is
so bad for Harvard and so bad for
typical liberals you're not be a
conservative to believe this I am sure
that both Sullivan and his wife Robinson
I'm sure that both of them oppose me on
politics thoroughly I'm pretty confident
of that but that does not matter the
basic principle which is that you don't
get rid of people because they are
acting as lawyers for somebody that you
oppose this is an astonishing thing 52
professors at the Law School signed a
letter supporting Sullivan saying his
commitments representing unpopular
clients was fully consistent with his
roles as law professor and faculty dean
at the same time the dispute took on a
racial element with some saying that
Sullivan was being treated unfairly the
Harvard black students black Law
Students Association criticized the
decision Sullivan himself said that it
may have been a racial thing I doubt
it's a racial thing my guess is that it
is it is just a left thing but the fact
that this is even a controversy is
pretty amazing okay now we're gonna get
to the woke scolds in Congress so again
it is amazing what the Democratic Party
is willing to allow in Congress the
radicalization of the Democratic Party
continues apace so we have been told
over and over and over again that Mike
Pence is an evil religious bigot and his
wife is an evil religious bigot for
teaching at a traditional Christian
school we've been told that Catholics
are bigots that Orthodox Jews are bigots
we have been told that virtually
everybody who happens to be traditional
in their religious practices is a bigot
except if you are a radical Muslim if
you are a radical Muslim then you are a
minority that ought to be given all
benefit of the doubt and not questioned
at all about your convictions which is
how you end up with Imam Omar Suleiman
the Akeem Institute for Islamic research
head giving the invocation in Congress
I'm gonna tell you something about this
Imam in one second this Imam endorsed by
the Democrats gave the invocation the
other day peace not war love not hate
benevolence not greed unity not division
and we commit ourselves to not betraying
our prayers with actions that contradict
them let us not be deterred by the
hatred that has claimed the lives of
innocent worshippers across the world
but emboldened by the love that gathered
them together to remember you
and gathered us together to remember
them may we honor one another glorify
you together oh this Imam was invited to
give the prayer by representative Eddie
Bernice Johnson now the invitation
itself by Democrats says something about
the Nemec rats he has every right to
give the invitation and the invocation
if he is invited the fact the Democrats
invited him is pretty phenomenal the
reason that it is phenomenal is because
this guy happens to routinely give
virulent ly anti-israel statements he
referred to Israel's an apartheid state
he called for a violent Palestinian
uprising in 2014 according to the
Washington Examiner on his verified
Facebook account Sulaiman called for
another Intifada that would be a violent
uprising against Israel usually that
ends with the murder of innocents in
Israel for the first time since 1967
Masjid al-aqsa is closed a third
intifada is near inshallah ending with
Alice will hashtag free Palestine o Aqsa
under attack laksa was never under
attack of course he constantly refers to
Israel's military operations as
massacres in a July 2014 a post he
posted a meme accusing Israel of
carrying on genocide okay it is not in
fact a genocide if there were a genocide
taking place against the Palestinians it
is the least successful genocide in the
history of the world considering the
radical increase in the number of
Palestinians who are living in these
territories sulieman' of course has been
a defender of representative Ilhan Omar
he said I'm not feeling me I know she
said some hurtful stuff messages she
never accused American Jews of double
loyalty or used anti entities and any
anti-semitic words of course which is a
lie
and Omar of course retweeted süleyman's
invocation the the radicalism of the
Democratic Party extends of course to
Rasheeda Talib who made a statement on a
podcast the other day that is so
astonishing in its radical dishonesty
that it is worth talking about so she
said that's quote there's always a kind
of calming feeling I tell folks when I
think of the Holocaust
okay well that's always an interesting
beginning to a sentence a calming
feeling I tell folks when I think of the
Holocaust and the tragedy of the
Holocaust and the fact that it was my
ancestors Palestinians who lost their
land and some lost their lives and
livelihood their human dignity their
existence in many ways have been wiped
out and some people's passports and just
of and just all of it was in the name of
trying to create a safe haven for Jews
post the Holocaust post the tragedy the
horrific persecution of Jews across the
world at the time
I love the fact it was my ancestors that
provided that right in many ways but
they did it in a way that took their
human dignity away and it was forced on
them hey all of this is such a lie like
all of it is a lie so to suggest that
the Jewish connection with the Land of
Israel his only post holocaust is simple
nonsense I mean it's just nonsense the
Jewish the Jewish presence in the land
of Israel has been consistent for about
3,000 years also the idea that Israel
was created in the wake of the Holocaust
because of the Holocaust is again simple
nonsense the Balfour Declaration in 1917
three decades preceding the Holocaust
the British government supported the
establishment of a Jewish state in the
area the Arabs in the area rejected it
that Jewish state by the way was
supposed to include Jordan as well in
1937 the British peel Commission
proposed a two-state solution also this
notion that the Palestinians were trying
to provide a home for Jews not only is
untrue it is a blatant lie the head of
the Palestinians at that time was a man
named Hajj was was man named Amin
al-husseini hey the Grand Mufti of
Jerusalem Muhammad Amin Oh Hussein II he
met with Adolf Hitler he was an ally of
the Nazis he specifically asked if Adolf
Hitler would make the final solution
applicable in the Middle East he
routinely incited violence against the
Jews he was one of the leaders of the
Arab war against the Jews in 1948 at the
establishment of the State of Israel the
official proclamation of the group led
by Hussein he said quote we appeal in
the very midst of the onslaught launched
against us now for months so the Arab
inhabitants of the State of Israel to
preserve peace this is what when the
official proclamation of the State of
Israel rather they said that they were
asking for peace they said they were
asking for the Arab citizens to stay
they asked people not to flee their
homes not to take up arms so every
elements what Rashida Talib says here is
just a lie the notion that the Arabs
provided a safe haven for Jews they were
they were bombing British targets and
trying to murder Jews in an attempt to
keep the Jews out one of the reasons
that the British would not allow more
Jews into Israel in the midst of the
Holocaust was to please the the Arabs
who were living in the area at the time
and were lobbying against it so all of
this is just a lie receded to leave his
wire but this whenever you whenever you
quote her this is very bad you can't
quote her so she tweeted out policing my
words twisting and turning them to a
night vile attacks on me will
work all of you who are trying to
silence me will fail miserably believe
me lady I'm not trying to silence you
that's why I'm quoting you says I'll
never allow you to take my words out of
context to push your racist and hateful
agenda the truth will always win
I agree the truth will always win which
is why people are quoting you Rasheeda
Talib I mean she's gonna like she can't
explain any of that the Democratic Party
of course will ignore all of this the
good news is that she's not the only
woman of Congress my favorite woke
member of Congress over the weekend
actually was AOC as always so the the
estimable AOC intellectual heavyweight
she tweeted out over the weekend that we
should tax the rich and then quote it a
said quote when we say tax the rich we
mean nesting doll yacht rich for-profit
prison rich Betsy DeVos student loan
shark rich
tricked the country into war rich
subsidizing workforce with food stamps
rich because that kind of rich is simply
not good for society and it's like ten
people so in other words she means when
we say taxing the rich people I don't
like no way that goes wrong giving them
the left the power to tax people that
they politically disagree with and don't
like that is the essence of the rule of
men not law that is the essence of
tyranny I don't like this person
therefore I'm going to tax them it's not
gonna be an equally applicable law it's
just going to apply to Betsy DeVos
that's it man the the the left continues
to grow more and more radical by the day
and it is a frightening prospect for
sure okay time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like over the over the
weekend I had the opportunity to read a
new book that is pretty fresh I think
it's out in the last month and a half or
so by tyler cohen the book is called big
business a love letter to an american
antihero and the book is really great
the book basically pushes the idea that
big business is not in fact bad for
america and many of the lies told by
critics of big business are just that
they are in fact lies and that is true
it is true the book is well worth the
read it goes through a lot of the myths
told about big business including the
idea that they are monopolizing American
industry including the idea that CEOs
that are paid wildly too much including
the idea the big business is somehow
worse qualitatively than small business
or that workers are treated worse by big
business than small business there are a
lot of myths that get busted here I
don't agree with Tyler coming about
everything
but there's a lot of stuff that I do
agree with the book is called big
business a love letter to an American
antihero
worth reading
when a big business is seriously under
attack okay time for a bevy of things
that I hate already so apparently
parents are naming their kids after Game
of Thrones characters um do not do this
do not do this particularly before you
know how the plots gonna go it turns out
that there are a bunch of people who
have been born in the last year named
Khaleesi um guys did you see last
night's episode yeah that's a bad move
there are a lot of bunch of people there
a bunch of people who name their kid dan
and Daenerys apparently aria is about
2500 people
Khaleesi 560 Yara Greyjoy 434 Liana so
apparently it's a lot of women
naming their girls like they're all girl
names Shay you name it really a named
her kid after a prostitute Renly
Baratheon a hundred and two people named
their kids Renly so they named their
kids after a younger brother who doesn't
have a claim to the throne and gets
killed in season one apparently 58 name
their kids Tyrion thirty name their kids
Jorah eleven name their kids Gregor like
after the I assume not the German name
it 11 naming their kids Gregor after the
mountain who was one of the worst kid at
world wars people 15 people named their
kid Ramsay as in Ramsay Bolton the worst
character in Game of Thrones most evil
character in Game of Thrones 14 name
their kid Theon how would you like to be
that fian they really about how long you
think it takes for the kids nickname and
reek 5 minutes 10 minutes really amazing
that people that people are so stupid as
I say the fact that 560 people name
their kid Khaleesi is pretty fantastic
ok this leads to my review of the last
episode of Game of Thrones so spoiler
alert if you have not watched the last
episode of Game of Thrones because it's
the last season and it's a cultural
phenomenon I've basically been reviewing
every episode
minor views tends to cut against the
brain so I was not a big fan of the
Battle of Winterfell it was shot through
a potato I couldn't see anything and
nobody of important died but it's time
for last night's episode so
overall I loved it overall I really
liked it so I liked it because it was a
return to the season one sensibility
that life is random people can get
killed at any time I also really like
I'm gonna give you the things I like
about it and then I'll give you the
things I hate about it so the things
that I liked about it the portrayal of
John and Tyrion is spot-on John has been
acting like Ned Stark like Robb Stark
he's been a stark the fact is he knew he
was the best guy for the throne he
decided to deliberately blind himself to
that out of his self-interest at not
being the guy who leads and that
cowardice led to a million people dying
in King's Landing
because Varys as I said was right there
is always the smartest guy on the show
and not only did John allow him to get
fried and this is a character ship for
John I mean John's showing some serious
cowardice here John is the guy who put
the the king of the who put the
king-beyond-the-wall mance rayder he
tried to save his life and then he put
him out of his misery when he was being
executed he did all of that because he
thought that the killing of mance rayder
was actually a bad idea John has
consistently been against the killing of
people who are potential allies Varys is
a potential ally okay the fact that he
goes along with Danny frying Varys is
pretty telling of John and the fact that
he knows what Danny is after having seen
that is pretty amazing so John is not
gonna end up on the Iron Throne
the mistake that the mistakes that he's
made are too grave he cannot end up on
the Iron Throne at this point and that's
great
hey tyrion exposed as the total fool
that he has been for several seasons now
Varys tells him what to do
tyrion not only doesn't go along with it
he then rats on Varys - to Daenerys
knowing what tenaris is about to do and
knowing that John has a better claim to
the throne and this is the episode after
he made in a specific appeal - Circe's
morality which made no sense at all
okay so tyrion is exposed as being a
fool and he deserves exactly what is
coming to him because that foolishness
has consequences for the million people
plus living in in King's Landing so that
was the best part of the show by the way
the person who is now the favorite to
take the Iron Throne has got to be Sansa
right she's the only person who has not
committed some sort of grave moral sin
here and also has been smart enough to
understand what Danny was
hey now he portrayal of Danny here's my
big problem everybody knew Danny was
gonna turn they did obviously create the
feeling that she was going to turn and
that was right I mean she had been
abandoned by all her advisors many of
her advisors from now attempting to stab
her in the back the ones who were loyal
to her are now dead all of that is
perfectly fine her decision to nuke the
city doesn't make any sense
it doesn't make any sense because she's
never seen the populations of the city
in which she lives as enemies and she's
seen the slavers at enemies in Mereen
she has seen the she even when the
people basically turn on her she doesn't
loose the dragons to murder all the
people that's not something that she
does the fact that she turns on the
people of King's Landing is is not only
a shock it's an unnecessary shock like
that she could have turned in a
different way like for example let's say
that last night after the bells start to
ring she the surrender has been had she
goes to the red keep and she nukes the
red keep and she takes care of Cersei
she kills Cersei and and then and she
does so in such a brutal fashion that
Aria and John decide they have to take
her out she tries to burn John out of
anger all that would have made sense the
fact that she nukes the entire city is
never properly explained you can see
that Benioff and Weiss really don't have
a great explanation for it and the post
shows talk about why she did that
they're like well in that moment she
sees that here's the place where her
ancestors that her ancestors built and
she's so mad and she's so alone that she
decides to what kill a bunch of children
nice never been in Danny's character so
you could have had her snap in a way
that makes a little bit more sense like
even it makes even Circe's blowing up of
the temple is small by comparison so
Danny doing this and becoming the most
evil character in the entire series
which that is I mean no one else in
Dukes in the entire city that is a turn
that was unnecessary in order for her to
be enough of a threat that she had to be
gotten rid of
for example that was a problem now we've
got another stuff I don't like the the
move to have Jaime basically become what
he was the beginning of season one and
then the battle with euron greyjoy is
completely worthless there is no reason
that your honor has to fight Jaime that
is nothing any
not even fanservice nobody was looking
for that you're on could have been
burned on the boat
everybody wouldn't find with that by the
way speaking of the burning of the city
he build up to two of her dragons get
taken down and the third is just
invincible why are they only firing one
arrow at the dragon at a time won't they
firing hundreds of arrows at the dragon
at the time the bolts at the dragon like
why wouldn't they do that it doesn't
make a lot of sense to make it come to
be so anticlimactic that she just nukes
the city with no opposition whatsoever
with one dragon is a pretty astonishing
move and I understand they wanted to do
the unexpected
but it's so abrupt that you end up with
this giant build up and then
unexpectedly a giant letdown you'd
expect Cersei to put up some sort of
resistance so that was so in any case
back to the you're on Jaime thing you're
on Jaime fight completely unnecessary
you're on is a crap character he's
always been a crap character so the fact
that he's the guy who stabs Jamie makes
no sense and then the fact that Jaime
basically walks off to killing wounds he
just kind of strolling around afterward
you didn't need that battle let's just
say the Jaime gets into the red keep
find Cersei and they both die in the in
the basement basically why do you need
to be wouldn't wounded by your on your
runs in need a send-off no one care what
happened to your on did she's gonna go
back and work with Zara's anyway who
cares so that's the you know so that
that I thought they twist on Jaime I
didn't think was great you know yeah I
think everybody kind of wanted the
moment where Jaime realized what Cersei
was instead of him just going back to
her and then her finally being
vulnerable at the end of the show is
again I thought a weird move so the
Jaime Cersei kind of full circle thing
wasn't a huge fan of that I know
everybody was into cleganebowl but
honestly not not into Clegane Bow the
only the best part of cleganebowl is
just when when Circe's hand just gets
wiped off the map in one second that
part's the best part but the whole he's
a zombie I'm gonna jump into the fire
okay fine I understand fanservice and
all that cleganebowl 20:19 so but
overall overall the idea that Arya is
helpless in the face of the dragon good
the idea that Jon and Tyrion made a huge
mistake good the fact that Dany loses it
and that she turns good so I'm much more
pleased at this season of Game of
Thrones than I was that I was at the
last season my predictions for the final
episode I think that Arya is now going
to have to
and tried to kill Danny I think Aria
will die I think they've kept her along
for alive for too long she doesn't have
a story arc beyond the beyond the show
so if they have guts
they will kill Aria which probably means
they'll keep her alive but John cannot
end up as king Danny will die Tyrion has
to pay some price for being a terrible
advisor and so I think that the most
likely scenario at this point is Shawn
says massan's I come in riding in on the
outside and that makes sense because the
entire sensibility of the show is sonses
sensibility which is moving from this
fantasy world where everything works out
great to being the cynical leader
necessary to do all of this by the way I
thought that Danny Stern was played well
specifically until she nuked the city
because she had turned from this
aspirational leader into a hardcore
leader like it makes sense from her
perspective nuking Varys makes perfect
sense from her perspective her saying to
Tyrion listen I'm not gonna lose the
city just to lose the city just for the
sake of humanity that makes sense from
her purse it's evil but it makes sense
from her perspective obviously so all of
it makes sense except for nuking the
city which is a step too far already so
I think with that review of Game of
Thrones we can end the show we'll be
back here later today for two more hours
or we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua ov era
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everyone I'm Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show Alyssa Milano is
staging a sex strike to protest
anti-abortion bills but of course if
you're on a sex strike you're not going
to need an abortion so the problem is
solved you know when it comes to
abortion when it comes to the
Constitution when it comes to free
speech conservatives are talking about
principle but all the left wants is
power we will talk about it on the
Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin